our voicemail number is two one nine two
david p this caller wants to know how
can we continue to push progressive
independent voices on to larger and
larger corporate media channels take a
listen
alright david i'm a big fan of the show
and i know a lot of people call in or
leave messages on the live thread asking
you to like when are you gonna debate i
cant defense or like when he then they
go on joe rogan things like that i was
wondering if there's anything we can do
as audience members to make that happen
whether it's like tweeting at certain
people or sending emails i was bored to
here in my yeah so listen the answer is
different with every show so for example
i eventually got on joe rogan not
because of all the people that tweeted
to him apparently he doesn't like people
tweeting guest ideas at him and or he
also doesn't look at anything other than
the verified feed if he's anything like
me because it's just a lot of nonsense
happening on twitter so eventually it
was that joe rogan saw a couple of my
clips and eventually invited me on i
don't know the answer but i think that
it would be really great if we continue
to politely tweet to sam Harris and to
bill maher and to whoever else i don't
think that it will hurt as long as it's
done politely right to the shows you
want to see me on as people know i will
appear anywhere that there is an
audience to be reached whether it's a
political conservative a politically
conservative politically liberal
non-political show whatever and i'll
continue doing the appearances as long
as the invites keep coming we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member or a patron to get instant access